this is why they have fact checkers
supposedly but yesterday on fox news
fox news did something that frankly i
haven't seen a lot and it does
demonstrate
the level of the news media's arrogance
when it comes to
not just fact checking news sources but
literally cutting them off
because they don't like what they are
saying okay so kaylee mcinerney was on
fox news and neil kavoda who i generally
like just cuts her off
right she's doing a presser accusing
democrats and voting irregularities and
again it's either going to be evidenced
or it's not going to be evidenced
and if it's not evidenced then people
are going to say that the kaylee
mackinnaney wasn't telling the truth all
of that is fair
but to cut her off literally in the
middle of the presser so that the
american people cannot even see the
information
this is where we now stand our bettors
right our media bettors have decided
what you can see and what you can hear
and that is not appropriate
social media have been doing the same
thing social media have been bullied
into shutting down true stories kevin
roose
who has literally bullied facebook into
lowering engagement on conservative
pages
it's insane facebook's entire company is
now being run by some woke staffers
and a bunch of idiots at the new york
times who write op-eds and send nasty
tweets about ooh look
look look shapiro's page dan bongino's
page mark levin's page
people are paying attention to them
that's really bad you guys should
downgrade them
kevin roose put out a tweet suggesting
it was disinformation to point out that
an election result in michigan did shift
it did shift that's not disinformation
you just don't like the narrative
tough but the idea here is that social
media and media are our saviors because
you see they are wiser than you and they
are wiser than i am and therefore they
get to censor what you see and what you
hear now again
i am happy to debunk any claim that is
false made by a republican or democrat
you can do that but first you have to
listen to the claim here's kaylee
mcinning being cut off by neil cavuto
yesterday
we want to protect the franchise of the
american people
we want an honest accurate lawful count
we want maximum sunlight we want maximum
transparency we want every legal vote to
be counted
and we want every illegal vote i just
think we have to be very clear
she's charging uh the other side is
welcoming fraud and welcoming illegal
voting unless she has more details to
back that up
i can't in good countenance continue
showing you this why why
i mean seriously couldn't he just come
on right after that and say you know i
don't think she provided any evidence of
those pretty
outrageous charges couldn't he just come
on i can't then good countenance
continue showing you this who are you
i mean seriously like what are you god
i can't you can't see that information
you might agree with that information
you might be
miserable misled you might be misled
right
yeah that would be a problem and there
thus you cannot see the information oh
that that's great
i want my media outlet censoring what i
can see what i can hear that that is
definitely what i am looking for here
and that kind of stuff from fox news
that that even the fox news host last
night tucker was like
you got like our own network is be
clowning itself here
okay that followed hard on an outtake
from sandra smith on fox news
uh acting exasperated when other guests
on fox news said oh you know what we
might want to wait for the legal process
to play itself out and sandra smith
didn't realize she was still on camera
and i was rather skeptical of this claim
whoever is decided to be the president
remember
just because cnn says or even fox news
says that somebody's present doesn't
make him president
so i think everybody needs to know that
this was done properly
and legally what is happening like trace
we've called it
okay we called it and therefore it's
called right and once the media call it
it is the truth that is the way that
this works
i only have one problem with this which
is that i don't trust the members of our
media to make objective determinations
not only that i certainly do not trust
the members of our media to determine
what i can see and what i can hear so
that i can determine whether their
determinations are in fact correct or
not
so when i say that you cannot trust the
establishment media i really
really really mean it right so we over
the past few weeks we have the specter
of a cnn contributor who had denied
on air that he was the anonymous author
from inside the trump administration
writing crap about trump
acknowledged that he was in fact that
person but he lied to anderson cooper on
air about it did cnn even suspend him
nope
and then today we find out that john
meacham
the presidential historian wrote the
speech that joe biden gave
on saturday night he's been writing
speeches for joe biden apparently all
along
and then he's been going on msnbc and
commenting on the speeches that he wrote
sources told the new york times
according to fox news that meacham had
been quote playing a larger role than
was previously known behind the scenes
both writing drafts of speeches and
offering edits on many of mr biden's big
addresses
including the one he gave at gettysburg
last month and his acceptance speech at
the dnc
biden campaign press secretary tj
ducklow told the times quote
president-elect joe biden wrote the
speech he delivered to the american
people on saturday night
but given the significance of the speech
he consulted a number of important and
diverse voices as part of his writing
process
as he often does meacham who publicly
endorsed biden back in march has long
been a go-to analyst
for msnbc the times reported that
according to a network source miesha
would no longer be a paid contributor
going forward but don't worry he'll
still be welcome as a guest
meacham did appear on msnbc following
biden's speech on saturday
he was asked by brian williams another
news anchor
who makes up stories about avoiding
gunfire in helicopters over a rock
i mean okay i'm sorry the specter of
brian williams who's a falsifier of his
own stories
asking questions to john meacham who
wrote a speech for biden
about that same biden's speech neither
disclosing that meacham was
actually the author of the speech that
is p that's peak media i mean that is
peak establishment media stuff right
there
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content